[Music]
in quarter store caroline news
corner store caroline i already know
every time i hear that
just from the title it's about somebody
that's racist because they always make
that
you know you know barbecue becky yeah or
some [ __ ] like that
i just read one today called golf cart
gale
yeah that's another idea something like
that i haven't seen that one
i love this [ __ ] yeah playing soccer
with these kids
oh my gosh crackhead karen uh submitted
by
submitted by fans since 2010 hashtag
ninjutsu
where were you in 2009 where were you in
2008 yeah where were you in 2007.
probably being born it's like ninja [ __ ]
it's just ninja ninja ninjutsu oh
it's a japanese person's last name dude
it's joe's last name
is it from a specific video ninjutsu is
like a ninja turtles thing right
no it's like saying karate yeah is it
real
yeah it is but not anymore
i thought it was a reference to like an
old video it's by far the sickest
sounding
of all the martial arts ninjas it's like
no one in japan really takes it
seriously except for what everybody
yeah everybody else there's it's big and
ninjutsu tourism is pretty big like a
lot of foreigners come to japan and like
they take ninja
camp and they do ninja school but like
it's just a bunch of chris farley's it's
so funny
it sounds like disney's version of what
uh martial arts is you know how like
they
take a real place and then they make it
like disney version like
this isn't karate it's ninjutsu yeah
there's a dude on naked and afraid who i
really liked but he was
apparently a ninja he was also black so
that was interesting that's like the
people i knew growing up who put weapons
on their walls and they had like
throwing stars
and like the klingon ballet thing oh the
uh yeah i forgot the
klingon blade yeah oh it's [ __ ] bat
left yeah
yeah and they thought that they're bad
asses and like i remember they would
take a sword down from the thing and
they would unsheath it and i was just
like yo
dude i'm pretty chill man you're a loser
bro they're like
this is martial arts right and then this
is larping this is ninjutsu right in the
middle
you don't know live-action role-playing
live-action role-playing like the
wizards
lightning bolt lightning bolt here's
what's weird about larping right and
weapon walls it's like bullying created
that person
but uh because they were bullied right
so then they like became outcasts in
their own group
but then they need bullying to come back
to society
you know what i'm saying no well they're
on an island right
because we bullied them to an island and
then now they're on the island doing
[ __ ] where we're like that's really lame
bro
so they need us still they need the
bullies still to correct their own
behavior because when they're
when they're live live-action
role-playing going lightning bolt
lightning bowl
there needs to be people standing there
like pointing and laughing
they know that it's not okay to do this
you know what's so fascinating i was
eating at lml
and there was this group of three people
and you could already
not even see just smell that they lived
in their parents basement and they were
talking about like we don't even have
basements in california but i'm saying
they built one just so they could just
hide in there
it was just as classic of a like 80s
like dungeons and dragons movie kid ever
long greasy hair like that brown shirt
with yellow lettering
the really weird baggy pants with the
cargo pants and [ __ ] and i've never
heard somebody so
passionate talking about a game in my
life like he was talking about how to
build a character to like the
[ __ ] tea and i just sat there eating
my food listening and staring at the guy
dude and it was he was and i felt so bad
because khalif was next to me
and i was like dude those three dudes
are like dude those dudes are [ __ ]
intense
and i felt so bad cause i said it out
loud and one of them was a girl dude i
could watch
i could watch a seven hour documentary
about these live-action role plays what
about a seven-hour documentary on
cornerstone carol oh yeah let's do this
i'm over it
we haven't done even the headlines okay
what is it do this
david i know i just said i felt really
bad because she heard me
here we go i'm going to read this
headline if you don't
oh do it tim take away his power god
damn it i don't even know i realized it
yet i said
[ __ ] [ __ ] wake up a woman has
apologized after wrong
wrongfully wrongly wrongly accusing
a nine-year-old boy of sexual assault
what do you do [ __ ]
cup her in the ass and go what's up baby
wait what the [ __ ]
a year old probably a kid you guys gotta
watch it you guys gotta watch it yeah so
this woman named theresa this oh by the
way this all happened in new york
so she was at this corner store
bodega yeah this bodega ooh bodega
that's when
she says that she felt this little
nine-year-old boy
grab her ass so then she starts like
getting into this verbal
thing with the mom and then that's when
the corner store
caroline she decides to go outside and
like
call the cops and so i'm going to show
you guys this video that went viral
it's a short for the word [ __ ] girl no
i want the cops here right now
because they think the police are coming
yeah how traumatic dude
who's that guy holding a case of beer he
was telling
me he was telling her to like leave oh
just leave like this girl
[Music]
poor little kid dude she
looks like a tight one too you remember
me right
from school she got aviators on and [ __ ]
like excited
right she claims to be a cop too
wait she impersonated yeah she claimed
to be a cop but then
when she's being interviewed and stuff
she's saying that the mom claimed to be
a cop and that the mom claimed that she
was going to arrest her
the [ __ ] proof that she said she was
wait you mean she was on the phone
saying she's a cop
no no no so like when she was arguing
because there all these people are
oh and they were recording they were
they were just like are you [ __ ]
kidding me you're calling the cops on
the nine-year-old kid like he didn't do
anything look he's clearly crying he
clearly didn't
i don't understand what how come every
single one of them somehow
just whips out this random credential of
their you know what i mean they're like
i'm a lawyer
yeah when they get nervous immediately
they go i'm a cop
i'm a lawyer like what everyone's a
lawyer now because they need a another
weapon
yeah they don't have any more weapons
like i would never do that
they're trying to power trip and have
authority yeah exactly that's what it is
because barbecue becky was like some
type of
uh what was it not a not a not a
scientist or some [ __ ] something i don't
know what she had some type of
credential i'm an astronaut
yeah what the [ __ ] does it have to do
with anything [ __ ] i'm an engineer
i'm gonna show you guys the surveillance
footage that came days after this video
went viral
which just completely proves the point
the truth here and you'd be lucky enough
if somebody touched your ass
so here she is she's bending over this
little boy is walking by
brushes up her back his backpack
backpack
was that brushed up against her clearly
she's a paranoid [ __ ] she look at her
she's like she's instigating by doing
that no she's on drugs oh you're all
talk
that's such drug that's a narcissist
behavior and then also probably coupled
with drugs absolutely no
way would that little boy touch your ass
that [ __ ] look
man just from that side profile that
[ __ ] was flat as [ __ ]
nobody want to touch that [ __ ] dude you
know what happened to me the other day
i was in pasadena right and this lady
she had like this chocolate croissant
you know like the she oh
she had she had a chocolate croissant
right and i was gonna ask her where she
got it and she goes uh not interested
and i was like
what did you wait how did it go down did
you see she thought i was like
i was i was like what'd you do i'll say
excuse me and then she goes
not interested i was like i just sat
there like wow
what just happened like oh did you tell
her i like i just sat i was like what
the [ __ ]
i just stood there like [ __ ] confused
i was like you didn't say anything
no because she went uh not interested i
went did she walk away
and i had a process in my head i was
like did she think i was hitting on her
yeah i was trying to feel when you got
the croissant [ __ ] because i should
look bumped it was like the one that was
like
it was like the one that's dipped in
chocolate so this [ __ ] [ __ ] just
thought i was and i just sat there just
[ __ ] pissed i was like hold on a
second you weren't even cute
like why the [ __ ] would you think it's
always the not cute one yeah
yeah you know what though i should ruin
my whole day
i heard that dude it's like oh you're
good the non-cute ones are
guys hit on them the most because they
are not intimidating
oh that makes sense so they're good
practice
yeah so i had a friend who was like
who's exactly like that she'd always be
like ew
get away from us like that kind of thing
and she was like the least attractive
person
what the [ __ ] is that about i was so
offended the loud annoying fat girl
is always the one who's like fat no i'm
not talking about your friend you're
talking about fat in there
it's absolutely true okay well i was fat
so like
you were probably annoying a lot too no
when when i was in high school it was
always the annoying loud doesn't want to
have a good day
no no i'm not talking about nikki no i
know who you're talking about you're
talking about the bodyguard of the group
yeah the bodyguards always do
the in the bodyguards and they're always
like they're always the one like going
like
oh no i'm not interested like oh this
guy was hitting me out but he was not
gonna be animating
she hangs out with the hot girls so she
thinks she's one of them
yeah but then like she's like the
booster seat for all the other girls
yeah the girl that
and then the designated protector she
would always go out with like playboy
bunnies and stuff
and then everyone and then she so she
needs to when she she wants to join the
conversation when they talk about
all the guys they have to fend off so
she's like oh yeah me too so then she
has to have those exactly i was like
so offended because i was like i was
like hold on a second
i'm above your league you don't get to
say that to me
especially i have a clothing line yeah
you know what i mean
i'm wearing all of it yeah you know what
i mean like i was like i just sat there
kind of shocked
it's like one of those situations you
don't know what to say you know i mean
because i didn't expect i'm not saying
because like in hindsight you could have
said the perfect thing back
but like you still didn't get to find
out where the chocolate croissant no i
was just sitting i just went
you know what i mean and then she just
started yapping off and walking away
with a friend and i was like
[ __ ] ugly [ __ ] that's not the only
thing i could think of yeah now you
won't even know where the croissant is
either yeah where the [ __ ] was that
chocolate croissant
that's what you get ben that's so funny
i would have loved it though if you
would have actually said like what i'm
not interested in you i just wanted i
wish i would have i just was so shocked
see her reaction that would have been
the cherry on because the word that
would have came out was like uh [ __ ]
like it would have been
yeah yeah i was just so shocked i've
never that happened to me twice
so like the other long ass story yeah i
like
penis yeah it was just so [ __ ] weird
this one's not that long actually it was
my friend
remember ed we went we went to go on
this like uh that [ __ ] hollywood hike
and then uh runyon cannon he brought his
homegirl over
and then we were just talking having fun
and then we didn't get to go on this
hike because it was so packed we
couldn't find parking
i was like hey he's like you want to
come out and just go on a hike with us
next time too she goes
no thanks i have a boyfriend and i was
like and i literally said to her i was
like uh
cool story i have a girlfriend she was
like oh my god i thought you were
hitting on me i was like what the [ __ ]
we couldn't go on a hike so i'm saying
do you want to go again next week with
ed i'm not asking you for me
you know what i mean like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude the amount of times that
you're hanging out with somebody and
then you you know what the [ __ ] at them
i don't even think i want to hang out
with you
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you dude she
i still mention it because
we're kind of cool now i still mentioned
to her till this day because it was so
[ __ ] embarrassing for her because ed
cause ed looked at me like what i just
asked you to go on a hike like what are
you talking about you went on a hike
with us today
yeah so why wouldn't you like why would
you think i was hitting on you dude like
what the [ __ ]
i don't think i've ever been like oh
this girl wanted me so bad
i don't think like that like what kind
of mind state are you in i mean it has
to be pretty obvious
yeah i don't think i've ever told a guy
that until they're
literally asking yeah and i'm like why
don't you even tell guys that when
they're like when you and you get with
them
but now it's different isn't it that's
different you tell them no no i tell
them
now i'm married cause she still doesn't
know you guys are married
are we still together
[Music]
[Music]
you